let's jump to this first story with us
from the post millennial
breaking dave rubin suspended from
twitter after defending jordan peterson
reuben offered a defense of jordan
peterson after he was suspended for
tweeting about actor elliot page
using that actor's name prior to paige
undergoing gender transition
so uh i think that's the real issue that
got him suspended
so dave
let me just pull up the actual tweet
here
so this is a tweet from jack posobik uh
reuben report has been suspended from
twitter for defending jordan peterson
rubin tweeted on june 29th the insanity
continues at twitter jordan b peterson
has been suspended for this tweet about
ellen page he just told me he will never
delete the tweet paging elon musk
that was hateful conduct
that
that tweet he issued a statement saying
i have been suspended by twitter for
posting a screenshot of jordan
peterson's tweet which got him got he
himself suspended while it is unclear
how i broke their terms of service it is
clear that they are breaking their
fiduciary responsibility to their
shareholders by letting a bunch of woke
activists run the company i hope elon
musk's purchase of twitter goes through
so he can blow up their servers and
humanity can move past this pervasive
twisted self-imposed mental institution
in the meantime you can find me at
rubinreport.locals.com
the platform i created to fight big tech
censorship something we need now more
than ever it's truly amazing i mean this
is the the the insanity of the world
we're living in but this is where it
gets crazy
let me jump to this uh let me i think i
have this tweet here buzzfeed news said
elliott page's dead name appeared as a
trending topic on twitter violating the
site's own policy on hateful conduct in
a statement to buzzfeed news a twitter
spokesperson said it was a mistake and
has since been removed
okay
that's it
i understand i think some social
networks have the the term that if you
reference a tweet or reference a post
that had gotten someone banned that that
reference is also a bannable offense and
this is to get people to stop people
from retweeting
things that had gotten banned because
then you're just kind of getting around
the ban it's reporting just factually on
what happened i think that's all that
dave rubin said but he said ellen page
which isn't you can't even acknowledge
that elliot page used to be known as
ellen page no you certainly can but
there are apparently they're so
arbitrary right you can they'll just
spam you or suspend this is like the
most heavy-handed nonsensical over
administration i've seen from twitter in
a long time let them do it the more they
do stupid ish like this the more regular
people are gonna be like what yeah dude
peterson's off the platform jordan
peterson now dave rubin's leaving like i
never used twitter from 2008 to 2020
because i thought it was insane and
redundant like i already have facebook
as my text platform i like the hashtag
system but it's just old tech like what
people you know i don't know anymore
yeah it's i mean it is it is a little
scary to see that
someone who is just
referencing something else happening
someone else getting getting taken off
the platform and talking about it around
the context can also be then taken off
the platform itself as well it's that
that is very alarming i will say that
from looking at dave rubin's
initial tweet about it it did look like
i mean you can look at it from maybe i'm
just playing devil's advocate here but
like you know he did say he did
reference her or her reference elliot
page as ellen page um without any
context of like you know like saying
that you know the artist formerly known
as as ellen page or something like that
you know what i mean is that okay though
i don't know is that allowed i don't
know that's still compelled speech yeah
over the weekend i was talking to a
five-year-old and i was he was like hey
stop calling me dude or man just do it
once a day and then call me by my name
the rest of the time i was like well
there's this thing called compelled
speech and he was like what is that and
i was like oh that five-year-old here we
go okay in the united states you can ask
people to say whatever but you can't
make them say whatever we have free
speech
right he you two five-year-old legit
said that too he asked me to call him by
his name and i was like well there's a
thing called conspelled compelled speech
where you can't make me say things so i
can i'm allowed to call you what i want
to call you you should have been like
for that i'm calling you dingus the
conversation got derailed before i
really was able to like you know
illustrate the law five-year-olds
usually are it's important it's
important okay then guess i won't call
you dude anymore there's this like
desire even of children to control
reality by making people do what they
want play the game i want it to be
played call me the name i want to be
called and like you're seeing adults do
it now it's really ridiculous are they
adults i think that you think you hit
the nail now with the hammer these
people are children i mean look at look
there's a subreddit called adulting you
ever see this
no you know what i'm talking about mary
just adults complaining about having to
do normal adult yeah they're like i had
to pay bills today
and they're like there was one it's
crazy there was a viral post about
adulting and it's like 35 year old
millennial dudes being like oh i had to
walk my dog today adulting it's like
okay but there was one post and it was
just like someone doing it was like it
went viral it was talking about their
frustrations with everything wrong with
the world like why do we have to live
this way like why am i dealing with
these things and it's like i get it i
get it you never grew up you never want
to grow up you have peter pan syndrome
whatever it's called you want to just go
off to never never land you want to hide
under the covers fine but stop voting if
you don't want to be in charge don't be
in charge you're making everything worse
this goes to the tribal lifestyle like
what we used to have where like a weak
person would would threaten the tribe's
existence if someone was severely
overweight or or just lazy or drugged
out all the time you you become a risk
for the tribe the tribe's going to deal
with you here's here's the thing you
were mentioning like dave did say ellen
page i don't think dave understands why
he wasn't allowed to do that
i think he was just like he sees jordan
peterson's tweet he goes whoa look what
he said about ellen page and they're
like ah you got the name wrong like how
is the the assumption here is that every
single person knows about the personal
life of elliot page yeah that's crazy
and to be fair people have known about
ellen page much longer than they've
known about elliot page so i mean that
you know someone could he he could very
well have made a just a very honest
legitimate mistake to say i i thought i
was referring to the right individual i
don't i don't think dave thought twice
about it yeah i think dave was just like
i can't believe this happened and just
did a quick tweet and that's it it's
like oh you've offended the woke police
the crazy thing about this though is how
uh buzzfeed complained to twitter and
twitter took a viral trend down
for real yeah so can i just say my
name's not tim anymore it's tom and then
all the tim pool trends just have to be
deleted
confusing everybody
technically i guess you could get it
legally changed that's funny not even
you should i don't
did did elliot page legally change their
name
probably i don't know
tons of people who change their names
just change it they don't go to the
courthouse and get it legally done some
people just be like my new name is you
know whatever prince
or it became a symbol i guess yeah i
heard that was for legal reasons though
i don't know that specifically but i do
remember that i mean the reason why they
said the artist formerly known as prince
is because they were like we need
something to be able to sign legal
documents yeah you can't just put a
symbol down like you can't do that you
need to have some kind of a legal name
so that's why they would they would
refer to him as is that under the law
though like you have to have a verbal
name
yeah
that i think i think also that's also
why
um elon musk said that they changed
originally what they wanted their son's
name to be him and grimes yeah um ash
whatever whatever
they said they had like
yeah but it's like they they narrowed it
down to ash or something like that but
like so originally he wanted like all
kinds of different symbols and things
that are not in the english alphabet and
so i guess the us government was like
you can't do that what's that
ultimately there's going to be a name
that you verbally call a child i mean so
yeah what was that going to be yeah
there there has to be there has to be
something like ash archangel but okay
something like that does it have to be a
like
germanic vernacular it has to be the
english alphabet it has to be the
english so you could theoretically go
like
yeah good luck saying that
if you say it wrong i'll get you panda
one syllable wrong
and then actually my my my given name
was
and i've changed it to wow
and so
if you get it wrong that's dead naming i
mean that's pretty true i can tell you
as someone with a not very common first
name that
that um that would be a a murderous name
to grow up with well yeah like i
remember i was talking i i was
mentioning your uh issue with um it was
when when washington post came after you
and it's so insane and i think i said a
light elite i have no idea oh yeah
that's right
where am i going to get banned because i
couldn't pronounce someone's name of
course you are officially henceforth
banned what was the wapo situation oh
that was taylor lorenz um how she
wrote an article about the the the
supposed influencers that really won
from the deputy heard trial
so she called you radicalized
in one of her subsequent tweets yeah she
said she called she said
well to be fair she referred generally
to radicalized
influencers and i don't know if she was
referring to me and that umbrella guy or
if she was referring to other
influencers that were commenting on the
whole situation
in in the the series of of of errors
that were not corrected um or if it was
like all of us all together but it is
the funny thing all right so here's the
the gist of the story is
you're you're a you do legal commentary
yeah you were commenting on the biggest
you know pop culture or one of the
biggest court cases in in the country
yeah and so she wrote this hit piece as
though you were a grifter just trying to
get money or whatever and i'm like it's
a lawyer talking about pop culture you
don't get more mainstream than that yeah
and then what happens is she she writes
fake news about you mm-hmm and then you
call her out
other people got mad yeah that she she
wrote fake news so she's like you're all
radicalized yeah if if you if you dare
correct me you're all radicalized that
that that's if that's
ideology
anti
taylor the rest is hillary she was kind
of like amber heard stan uh
no she's not well
amber heard wrote for the washington
post
that's where supposedly or ghosts well
right right ghost road but the point is
the article was published
taylor lorenz works for wapo yeah so of
course there's a major conflict of
interest yeah yeah there is they were
thinking about taking that down
but i think they just added a note i
don't i don't recall if they actually
ended up adding a note to it but my my
assumption was that they were never
going to take that down unless they were
actually compelled to do so
that's that's what i that's what i was
assuming even at the very should be
compelled to take it down dude taylor
lorenz has like been having major
meltdowns like her she's losing yeah it
reminds me of like an abused dog when
it's more likely to snap out and lash
out at people coming up to pet it like
if an animal's been abused it's more
likely to attack someone that comes near
it
usually for the most part who did
anything to taylor lorenz who knows what
her childhood was like but for her to
see danger all around
school bro yeah so but a lot of rich
people are twisted when they're kids
that's like bad parents it's not just
that it's that they're their their
snowplow parents clear out all obstacles
so they never actually experience any
hardship so then they get older i feel
the lightest snowflake touches their
skin and they scream i don't want ilfor
or anything but for her to be seeing
radicalization all around her is like
and yeah there is radicalization going
on reality this fifth dimensional
warfare weird you know twisting but
it's you know obviously if you see it
all around you then you gotta look
within because it's your own lens that
you're seeing reality through that's
making it look a certain color i saw
this viral tweet i didn't fact check it
so fact check me on this one but uh
someone tweeted taylor lorenz actually i
think was viva so i trust it uh that she
was like people are getting sick at
vidcon with kovitt because vidcon
literally did nothing to mitigate uh
kovid and then he also posted a tweet
from vidcon where it's like you know
vaccine and negative tests and masks are
acquired or something like that
maybe not mask but it was like you know
you need a negative test within three
days to come to the event so taylor
lorenz is literally just making stuff up
yeah now look i don't care about this
woman but the issue is she is wielding
the washington post like you know what
was that what was the name of the sword
that he-man had whatever that one she's
wielding it like i don't know if it had
a name that's awesome that sort of
graceful or something was it yeah i
don't know she's holding up the
washington post and using it to to smack
people around and cause damage to other
people that's the problem
yeah i mean and the power sword it's
called the power supply power sword no i
was gonna say that i mean the issue that
that
that i had with with my my run-in and
with tugs run in with her was that it
was it was just it was it was something
that really shouldn't have been an issue
it should have been just a very simple
correction to say like okay we're
correcting at where i said that i
reached out to them for comment and no i
didn't reach out to them for comment
until after we had published but they
had several corrections on there where
ultimately they uh it it said that um
the the final like resting place of this
like laundry list of corrections was
that um it said that that she had not
reached out to
um tug at all beforehand um but she had
reached out to me by instagram which is
literally the last place that she
reached out to me after twitter dm which
was after i called her out on twitter
now this is the crazy thing they play
this game where they'll be like we
reached out to ian for comment he did
not respond and then like what does that
mean it turns out they sent a letter in
the mail yeah to an old address to an
old address yeah smoked signal like we
did legally for for a legal party
out into the woods but there was no
response yeah yeah it'd be funny if
there was and the thing he got back to
me they didn't it didn't even if i
remember correctly i didn't even say
that we had that we had not responded to
comment but that we had declined or that
we we had we had essentially refused to
comment yeah but that would require a
response from us maybe instead of reach
saying we reached out they should start
saying they received our request for
comment and did not respond because
reaching out is different than
it doesn't even reach out for comment in
the middle of a
of a forest and yeah in the middle don't
be surprised when you don't hear back
yeah
but that's the game they play yeah
they'll they'll they're they're i can't
remember this
but they they do this thing where
they'll like send a general inquiry to
your like info line on your website
which is you know like a low level level
like so you know but joe rogan never
responded you know because they like
went to his website and submitted a form
to his booking manager who threw in the
trash and didn't know what it was to
info at joergan.com yeah things like
that they will or they'll like look your
name up in the phone book and they'll
call it and be like they didn't comment
you're like bro there's a bunch of
people of the same name as me who are
you looking up it should say that we
were unable to
contact we were unable to get in touch
with someone for content but that's also
just not true
because you have to try and we did not
that'd be a better way we did not get in
touch with them for comment yeah i i
what they what they do with these
comments is they're trying to feign
credibility that's the whole point
and they want you to seem less credible
so they'll be like oh they never got
back to us that's their fault but here's
here's the thing even if you get back to
them they're going to twist whatever you
say yeah they're going to mangle it up
you know you're going to say something
like uh look i'm a legal youtuber i'm
commenting on a very publicly you know
public trial and i'm taking my
my expert opinion uh for what it is and
then they'll write when they responded
they expressed that it's a very popular
trial and it's good for business
and then when you're like i didn't say
that well that's how we assumed it to be
yeah and then what are you gonna do or
something along the lines of like this
is yet another lawyer
profiting off of poor people and their
misery yep so should you send a video
response as your comment and then
the video response online later when
you're like this is where they got the
comment from so so or just a public
tweet but but it is better to do a
public tweak because everyone can read
it but they will write whatever they
want sure right so i'll tell you this
ian how do you feel about um
bakery fresh cinnamon buns
well i'm not down with the carbs but you
know it smells good when asked for
comment on bakery fresh cinnamon buns
ian let out a displeasing grunt
seemingly showing dissatisfaction
commenting not pleased dot dot dot he
even wanted to say that there were
problems with that he said i'm not into
dot dot the smell
exactly and then people are gonna but
but imagine that from uh so so that's
actually a good example because people
are gonna be like what sane person does
not like the smell of bakery fresh
cinnamon of course what is wrong with
you right now imagine though it's
something very similar to that but like
political violence or january 6th or
something and you'll say something like
obviously no one's going to come out and
say i support all of this violence and
they're going to be like he responded
with dot quote i support all of this i
had this thought over the weekend that
whoever controlled in the past whoever
controlled the newspapers controlled
politics like you could write whatever
you wanted and twist the entire world
now it's just that with social media
like twitter took down a hashtag of a
trending that's not how trending works
trending is what's trending yeah it's
really funny the reason they did it too
somebody was like i don't like that name
stop letting people talk about it at
some point i think people will be fed up
with private corporations controlling
politics
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there is a massive library
to check out so again go to timcast.com
or tune in monday through friday at 8pm
we'll see you all there
you